THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP RAGING AGAINST
DEMOCRATS AND HOUSE SPEAKER,
NANCY PELOSI, AFTER SHE ACCUSED
HIS ADMINISTRATION OF ENGAGE NG
A, QUOTE, CRIMINAL COVER-UP."
IT CAME IN RESPONSE TO TRUMP
SAYING HE WOULD BE OPEN TO
HEARING DIRT ON HIS 2020
OPPONENT FROM A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT.
THE PRESIDENT CLARIFYING THOSE
COMMENTS EARLIER TODAY.
>> IF I WAS -- OF COURSE, YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT IT.
OF COURSE, YOU GIVE IT TO THE
FBI OR REPORT IT TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OR SOMEBODY LIKE THAT.
BUT, OF COURSE, YOU DO THAT.
YOU COULDN'T HAVE THAT HAPPEN
WITH OUR COUNTRY.
IF I THOUGHT ANYTHING WAS
INCORRECT OR BADLY STATED, I
WOULD REPORT IT TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, THE FBI.
I WOULD REPORT IT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT, ABSOLUTELY.
>> COMING OUT SWINGING AGAINST
PELOSI'S ABSURD ACCUSATION AND
POINTING THE FINGER BACK AT THE
SPEAKER AND HER OWN PARTY.
>> THIS IS PROBABLY THE WORST OR
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE WORST
POLITICAL SCANDALS IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
THEY SPIED ON THE OPPOSING
PARTY'S CAMPAIGN USING THE
INTELLIGENCE APPARATUS OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IT'S A FASCIST STATEMENT.
IT'S A DISGRACEFUL STATEMENT.
I CALL HER NERVOUS NANCY.
SHE IS A NERVOUS WRECK.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED,
HILLARY CLINTON, WITH THE MONEY
THAT ULTIMATELY WENT TO RUSSIA
FOR THE FAKE DOSSIER, THAT TOTAL
FAKE PILE OF STUFF, THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT WAS PAID AND PAID
BY HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC
AND IT WENT TO RUSSIA, THAT'S
THE CRIMINAL.
>> HE ALSO BLASTED THE ON GOING
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATIONS
INTO THE MUELLER REPORT CALLING
THEM UNFAIR.
>> ISN'T IT AMAZING THAT
CONSTANTLY EVERY DAY SOMEBODY
GETS A LETTER, COME INTO
CONGRESS, COME INTO CONGRESS.
IT IS LIKE DEATH THROUGH 1,000
WOUNDS.
I WILL TELL YOU, IT IS SO UNFAIR
WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
I REALLY THINK THAT PEOPLE ARE
WISE TO IT.
>> WE ALWAYS COME BACK, DANA, TO
TRUMP AND NERVOUS NANCY PELOSI.
>> THEY ARE GOING TO SHOW DOWN
RIGHT TO THE FINISH.
>> A SHOWDOWN ON A FRIDAY.
>> A CRIMINAL COVER-UP, I GUESS,
IS THE LATEST.
>> YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PUT
UP SOME PROOF SOON IF YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO THIS.
THEY HAVE ALREADY DONE THE
MUELLER REPORT.
I DON'T SEE HOW THEY COME UP
WITH SOMETHING ELSE THAT IS
GOING TO CHANGE PEOPLE'S MINDS.
I DON'T.
I WOULD BE WILLING TO LOOK AT
IT, FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE.
I'LL LOOK AT IT.
MAYBE I WILL HAVE TO REPORT IT
TO THE FBI.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT
WHISPER IN YOUR EAR, OH, THERE
IS SOMETHING AND THERE IS NEVER
SOMETHING.
I UNDERSTAND WHY HE IS
FRUSTRATED ABOUT IT.
HE FEELS LIKE HE HAS TO CONTINUE
TO BE ON OFFENSE BECAUSE HE
DOESN'T WANT TO BE ON DEFENSE.
THAT'S TO THE EXCLUSION OF
EVERYTHING ELSE.
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
YOU CAN'T RUN ON THE ECONOMY IF
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE FIGURED OUT
THEY CAN MAKE HIM TALK ABOUT
THIS EVERY SINGLE DAY AND MAKE
THIS THE STORY, MAYBE THEY THINK
THAT HELPS THEM.
IT DOESN'T HELP ME.
>> HE HAD AN EXCELLENT EVENT THE
OTHER DAY WITH KIM KARDASHIAN.
>> WHY ARE YOU LAUGHING?
IT IS A GREAT CAUSE.
>> IF SHE WAS THERE AT THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE, WE WOULD BE READING
STORY AFTER STORY ABOUT HOW AN
AMAZING EVENT THIS WAS.
IT WAS BURIED TODAY.
>> I YOU WOULD TUNE IN T
>> I YOU WOULD TUNE IN "WATTERS
WORLD" AND HE WOULD MOCK HIM.
>> WE ARE BACK TO YESTERDAY.
>> NO, WE ARE NOT.
YESTERDAY, I SAID, THIS GUY JUST
DID SOMETHING THAT WAS BASICALLY
FAILING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF I CHEAT TO
GET REELECTED, I'M GOING TO DO
SOMETHING ILLEGAL.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT HE SAID.
>> TODAY, HE BACKPEDALLED AND HE
SAYS TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, OF
COURSE, I WOULDN'T TAKE DIRT ON
MY OPPONENT.
I'M THINKING, JESSE MUST THINK,
YEAH, I GUESS JUAN WAS RIGHT.
>> I NEVER THINK THAT.
THAT'S NEVER HAPPENED.
I THINK HE SAID THE OTHER DAY, I
WOULD LISTEN AND MAYBE I WOULD
GIVE IT TO THE FBI.
YOU STILL HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
ANSWER THE FACT THAT HILLARY
PAID FOR THE FOREIGN DOSSIER.
TRUMP NEVER PAID FOR ANYTHING,
NEVER GOT ANYTHING.
HILLARY GOT IT AND PAID FOR IT.
>> YOU KNOW WHY I LIKE SITTING
NEXT TO YOU.
IT'S SO OBVIOUS TO THE AUDIENCE.
>> IT'S CALLED CONTENT.
>> I WILL ACKNOWLEDGE BOTH
SIDES.
I THINK IT IS A REALLY FOOLISH
THING THE PRESIDENT SAID.
I DON'T THING ANYBODY SHOULD GO
OUT OF THEIR WAY TO JUSTIFY HIS
REMARKS TO GEORGE
STEPHANOPOLOUS.
HE DID ENOUGH DAMAGE IN THIS
REALM.
HE NEEDS TO DROP IT.
WHAT HE SAID TODAY, HE SHOULD
HAVE SAID IN THAT INTERVIEW.
YOUR ISSUE IS WITH THE MEANS AND
NOT THE END.
IT SHOULD BE WITH THE END.
IF THE ULTIMATE PROBLEM WE HAVE
IS RUSSIAN OPERATIVES ARE TRYING
TO INFILTRATE CAMPAIGNS IN ORDER
TO EFFECT THE OUTCOME OF
ELECTIONS, WE SHOULD HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT.
NOW, PEOPLE LIKE ANDY McCABE, HE
IS JUST WORRIED ABOUT THE MEANS.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
INTELLIGENCE LAUNDERING, WHICH I
THINK IS INCREDIBLY PROBLEMATIC,
BECAUSE IT WENT THROUGH A LAW
FIRM AND THE DNC AND A BRITISH
OPERATIVE.
THAT'S OKAY, EVEN THOUGH THEY
PAID MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO THE
SAME COMPROMISED PEOPLE WHO WERE
DOING THE EXACT SAME THING.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS, THEY GOT
ENRICHED IN THE PROCESS.
THOSE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
ROBERT MUELLER HAD AN ISSUE
WITH.
THE OTHER THING ABOUT NANCY
PELOSI.
>> LET ME RESPOND.
>> YOU HAVE TO KEEP A LITTLE
LIST.
THE OTHER THING ABOUT NANCY
PELOSI, SHE IS BASICALLY SAYING
HE DID A HORRIBLE JOB, WITH
ROBERT MUELLER.
IF THIS IS A CRIMINAL COVER-UP
AND WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
RISES TO IMPEACHMENT, THAT'S
BASICALLY SAYING THAT ROBERT
MUELLER ISN'T COMPETENT.
>> DIDN'T BILL BARR SAYS HE
THOUGHT ROBERT MUELLER WOULD
COME TO A CONCLUSION AND HE
DIDN'T.
>> HE COULD HAVE USED MORE
FORCEFUL LANGUAGE.
>> NERVOUS NANCY, SHE IS A
NERVOUS WRECK.
HE IS GOING TO STICK WITH THIS
NAME.
>> HE LIKES NERVOUS NANCY.
THE IMPORTANT NICKNAMES ARE THE
ONES HE IS GOING TO BE RUNNING
AGAINST.
I AGREE, THAT QUOTE BY McCABE IS
AMAZING.
THIS IS GOOD THAT TRUMP IS DOING
HIS OWN FIGHTING.
HE GETS OUT AND SAYS THIS IS THE
BIGGEST CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY
EVER.
WHAT A CRAZY PERSON.
ANDREW McCABE, WHAT HE SAID WAS
SOMETHING A RIGHT WING TALK SHOW
HOST WOULD SAY.
HE SAID, FOR A CAMPAIGN TO HIRE
A LAW FIRM, AN AMERICAN LAW FIRM
AND HIRES ANOTHER AMERICAN
RESEARCH COMPANY WHO CONTRACTS
OUT WITH A FOREIGN INDIVIDUAL,
THIS IS ANDY McCABE, THAT'S NOT
ILLEGAL.
THAT'S FINE.
THAT'S JUST SWAMP AT WORK.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
THEY ARE ALL ADMITTING TO WHAT
HAPPENED.
THEY ARE SAYING, NO, NO, THAT'S
THE WAY WE DO IT IN WASHINGTON.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE THE MEDIA CAN
TALK ABOUT THIS PSEUDOSCANDAL
WITH THE HYPOTHETICAL THING THAT
TRUMP SAID OR DID OR DIDN'T DO.
YOU HAD HILLARY CLINTON MOVING
$9 MILLION TO THE DNC, TO THE
LAW FIRM, TO THE FOREIGN
NATIONAL FROM THE U.K., WHO GETS
ALL OF THE DIRT FROM RUSSIAN
POLITICAL OPERATIVES,
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS AND
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS.
THAT IS LITERALLY PAYING FOR
FOREIGN DIRT.
THE MEDIA IS NOT TALKING ABOUT
THAT.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE YOU ARE HAVING A
FEVERED DREAM.
>> WHAT'S THE KEY POINT?
>> EVEN WITH THE STEELE DOSSIER
THAT YOU GUYS ARE FIXATE
THAT YOU GUYS ARE FIXAING ON,
GUESS WHAT HE DID?
>> WHAT?
>> HE REPORTED IT TO THE FBI.
>> HE GAVE IT TO BRUCE OHR.
>> AND WHAT DID HE DO WITH IT?
HIS WIFE WORKED FOR FUSION GPS.
>> HE GAVE IT TO THE GOVERNMENT,
JESSE.
>> WAS HE GIVING IT TO THE
GOVERNMENT FOR WHAT REASON,
JUAN?
BECAUSE HE WANTED TO WIRETAP THE
PRESIDENT.
>> HE SAID IT IS ALARMING.
>> HE PAID RUSSIANS TO TELL HIM
LIES ABOUT TRUMP AND THEN GAVE
IT TO THE GOVERNMENT AND SAY,
HEY, GUYS, TRUMP DID SOME NASTY
STUFF IN A HOTEL.
WHY DON'T WE LOOK INTO THAT?
>> LET'S KEEP THE SEX LIFE OUT
OF THIS.
I AM SAYING THAT WHAT WE HAVE
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SAYING HE WOULD
TAKE FROM A FOREIGN POWER.
YOU GUYS ARE SAYING, HILLARY DID
THE SAME THING.
OF COURSE NOT.
WE HAVE OPPOSITION.
NOT ONLY DID SHE TAKE IT, SHE
PAID FOR IT.
>> DOESN'T IT MAKE THE PRESIDENT
SO -- DOESN'T IT GO TO SHOW THAT